What do you think, David?
This is provable.
>> Some said that no,
based on the knowledge that we're
given here about the mug, a pot, and
an object, and
the things that we know from the past,
we can't actually prove
that this object is a mug.
We can prove that the object is stable,
and
enables drinking based on what we
saw with the proof of the cup.
The object we're dealing with here,
had all the same criteria as our object
in the other example in addition.
To these thick sides,
and being made of clay.
So because we had everything else,
we were able to easily prove that
it's stable and enables drinking.
But what we can't do is we
can't link protecting its heat
to limiting heat transfer.
Nothing in my definition of pot
actually tells me that the fact that it
limits heat transfer actually
protects against heat.
So, while for my definition of
pot I can abstract that because
my new object has thick sides and is
made of clay, it limits heat transfer,
I can't make that last connection
to protecting against heat.
>> That is good David.
Now let's make sure that we understand
the processing that David did.
He wanted to show that
the object is a mug.
So he looked at the conditions,
the open conditions of
proving that the object is a mug,
and there were three of them.
For each of them,
he tried to build a proof.
He could do so for the first two,
but this was the open one.
So he came up with the closest example,
that was the pot.
And he did the abstraction here, but
he was unable to link these two,
because there is no knowledge which
links these two at the present time.